rumor says that there is a mysterious
island in the south pacific where the
entire population is women people call
it the virgin island it is also believed
that the women clan has a mysterious
seed which causes them to age 10 times
slower than normal humans therefore many
people are trying to find the location
of the island and who wouldn't one of
them is mr song who wants to become
immortal so he has been sending his men
of experts and explorers to search for
the island elsewhere wang the
protagonist of the movie listens to a
news report about mr song who has once
again funded a large sum of money for
his expedition to search for virgin
island the news then adds about the
mystery of the island detailing that
none of the explorers who participated
in the expedition so far have survived
till now only one person has ever set
foot on the island a famous explorer
named lee lee is none other than wang's
father but he never came back from the
island and left no message for the world
or for his son it is rumored that he was
mesmerized by the beauties on the island
so he decided to stay there permanently
those rumors are almost certainly true
determined to find his father wang
decides to participate in mr song's
expedition and heads off to the shore to
board a ship there he meets a friend
hyun-woo who claims to be an expert
navigator as he has recently graduated
from the somali navy seals after setting
up everything wang and hyun board the
ship and just as they are about to take
off one of mr song's men approaches them
and hands over a gps tracker after a
while the two finally hit the ocean
hence kickstarting their adventure
initially they are hopeful about the
mission but after two months of
wandering into nothingness they become
pessimistic
by this time their food supply has also
run out so they pray that they reach the
island soon one day while the boys are
complaining about the gps not working a
flock of birds flies over them wang who
is lying on his back feels the drip on
his face and when he smells it he
realizes that it's seagull poo this
indicates that they are near an island
and when wang peers through his
binoculars he confirms the news and
shares it with his friend wang has never
been this happy to be put on in his life
unfortunately the high tides do not
allow the boys to dock their ship so
they are forced to swim all the way in
the next scene when the two friends wake
up on the shore they notice an army of
women surrounding them while still not
fully conscious wang asks if they're
finally on the virgin island but the
women just keep on staring and remain
silent later the two are brought to
their camp for interrogation as usual
hyun becomes overconfident and tries to
smack talk the women but ends up getting
beaten by a durian stick because of the
incident the boys are locked inside a
wooden cage as a punishment in the
meantime the leader of the women who
they refer to as patriarch approaches
the two and starts talking she mentions
that only a handful of people have
breached their island in the past 500
years but all of them were experienced
navigators hyun is in disbelief that the
girls have been around for such a long
period and jokingly asks if they are
really immortal however the patriarch
and her women simply leave them behind
and go about their ways once the women
are out of sight wang takes out his
hidden knife and plots with hyun to
escape at nightfall they succeed in
their plan and eventually get out of the
prison after this wang decides to check
out the tribe for any clues while hyun
sets out to find ways to escape the
island the next scene shows hyun heading
towards the jungle to see if there's a
way out while wang arrives at the
women's village and enters one of the
huts it turns out that the women have
filled the jungle with traps so hyun wu
unknowingly falls for them at first he
falls down a rabbit hole below and then
gets pierced by a wooden arrow through
his back to make the situation worse he
also gets hammered by several coconuts
on his head meanwhile mu yan a typical
innocent sister of the women's tribe and
her sister moon enter the hut in which
wang has been snooping around
surprisingly the hut is a bathing place
for the islanders and when muyon starts
taking off her clothes and preparing for
her bath wang tries to sneak his way out
of the room unfortunately he gets caught
by the girl's sister who doesn't let him
go wang tries to bribe the girl with a
treat but she eventually screams
alerting every other woman in the
village terrified wang runs for his life
while the women chase after him with
spears he tries his best to scare them
off but eventually gets captured in the
trial room the patriarch tells wang that
breaking out of prison is a sin in their
culture and that trying to attack the
clan assures a deathly punishment just
then a bruised and battered hyun arrives
at the scene to rescue his friend he
threatens the clan that he is a trained
soldier who knows combat skills but the
women only get irritated by his lies and
beat him once again the clan believes
that being seen by a man when they are
naked makes them ugly hence they demand
to execute wang and his friend but
before readying the boys for their final
right the patriarch is curious to know
why they visited her island wang
responds that he is in search of his
father who came to the island 10 years
ago to his surprise the patriarch
reveals that she had met his father but
she too is looking for him she mentions
that if she ever sees his father again
she will kill him saying this much she
orders her women to take the culprits to
their sacred tree and grill them there
he unpleads with the women that he
wasn't the one who saw muyon in such a
condition and asks to be released but to
no avail next the women prepare the
grill while the boys are tied and kept
separately in two giant barrels hyun
fears that they're being marinated
before being roasted but he is
interrupted by muyon who has finally
come to face her pervert she lashes out
at wang for spying on her and tells him
that to lift the curse of being ugly she
has to kill him however just when it
appears that she is about to finish him
off with a knife she instead cuts open
his rope before letting the two escape
the innocent muyon asserts that she
hates wang but at the same time she
doesn't want him to die because of her
unfortunately the boys take the jungle's
way and fall for the set traps the
following morning wang and hyun are once
again captured and tied in front of the
sacred tree the women prepared different
kinds of ingredients and light a fire to
marinate the boys and eat them after
roasting but the process is interrupted
when chanhua one of the women from the
clan drowns in the ocean while the women
rush to the shore the boys take this
opportunity to escape by burning their
tight ropes they also flee the scene not
realizing that they have put fire to the
sacred tree meanwhile the women cry in
pain after seeing their friends
struggling in the ocean the two friends
prepare to use the distraction to sneak
out of the place but at the last second
wang changes his mind and decides to
help the drowning girl without thinking
about the time when the islanders wanted
to kill him and his friend wang goes to
the shore and swims in the ocean to
rescue chanhua after he brings her back
to the shore hyun jumps into action and
prepares cpr on an unconscious chanhua
fortunately she starts breathing again
and the women applaud the boy's bravery
later wang and tian are once again
brought in front of the patriarch chunwa
wants her leader to excuse the boys as
they saved her life at this point she
has already started to develop feelings
for hyun the patriarch also thinks of
pardoning the boys but just then she is
informed that their sacred tree has been
burned and destroyed after getting to
know that wang and tian are behind this
incident the patriarch decides to
execute them immediately however mu yan
and chanhua suggest they give the boys
one last chance as a result the
patriarch reluctantly gives them three
months to restore the tree if the tree
doesn't come back to life they will be
killed mercilessly the next day wang and
tian try their best to polish charcoal
off the tree and water it as time passes
the boys become close to the women as
they help them in their everyday life
with the use of their modern tools and
techniques wang and tian catch huge fish
and teach them to grow vegetables
meanwhile chanhua tries her best to grab
hyun's attention and brings him flowers
and durian every day one day when wang
tries to find a signal on his gps he
notices a viper lurking behind muyon he
immediately springs into action and
rescues her as the two lay down in a
romantic manner muyon reveals that the
snake is actually her pet the following
day wang and tian are elated to find the
sacred tree sprouting later that night
all the island women along with the boys
celebrate with a feast and dance
together wang notices mouyan peacefully
dancing and remarks that the value of
life isn't about the length of time but
rather about something that is worth
protecting with your life he then notes
that he is lucky to have found it as he
wants to protect muyon and her tribe
sometime later muyon approaches wang and
tells him about the history of their
tribe she shares that a long time ago
there was an all-women tribe known as
the witch tribe they reproduced by
parthenogenesis they were the tribe
closest to nature among primitive humans
responsible for guarding the seed yuan
which contained the secrets of life
their mission was to protect the balance
between nature and life however as human
settlements expanded their thirst for
killing increased and one day they
eventually found out about the seed yuan
hence a genocide-like hunt was carried
out on the witch tribe to protect the
seed the head of the clan gave it to the
youngest woman in the tribe and asked
her to run away as far as possible the
girl witnessed her entire family being
killed but as told she escaped the place
not long after she woke up on a deserted
island and saw that the seed she carried
had started sprouting all over the place
the deserted island gradually became
full of life slowly the girl got older
and a new witch clan flourished on the
island continuing to guard the yuan seed
muyon then reveals that the young woman
is none other than the patriarch and
that they are the descendants of the
witch clan the following morning she
takes wang to the place where she had
last seen his father there wang finds
his father's old journal where he is
written about his time with the witch
clan he writes that it was because of
their warm gesture kindness simplicity
and reverence for life that he didn't
want the expedition to destroy their
life so he never reported back hoping
that the clan and their secrets of life
remain secluded from the greed of modern
man he then concludes his journal
portraying his worry for wang and hopes
that his son will understand the choices
he made in the next scene wang realizes
what he has to do and destroys the gps
tracker but before he and hyun can walk
away they hear a beep coming from the
gps indicating that it's still working
elsewhere mr song is notified about the
island's location the boys then rush to
the patriarch and warn her to leave the
island immediately as mr song and his
men are on their way to get the seed
that they have been protecting they then
devise a plan to seduce the men lure
them in and take them out one by one
soon enough mr song arrives with his
crew and orders four of his men to check
the island the men arrive at the village
but they are surprised to see beautiful
women waiting for them we weren't
expecting to see women on this island of
women next the women play their part get
the men drunk and successfully knock
them out after his men don't report back
mr song himself ventures into the island
and starts his inspection wang and hyun
greet him at the gate and try to
convince him that it isn't the virgin
island that he was after but mr song is
no fool so he orders his men to tie up
the women along with the two boys he
then threatens the patriarch and asks
her for the secret of life so that he
can become immortal like them when she
refuses mr song threatens to kill moon
as a result the women reluctantly guide
mr song and his men to the place where
they have hidden the yuan seed however
on the way when chan hua knocks down a
man the whole tribe fights back
meanwhile mr song escapes the place with
wang and forces him to wear a time bomb
he then threatens to detonate it if he
doesn't reveal the secret of the witch
clan just then hyun along with the women
arrive at the scene and subdue mr song
however during the process mr song
manages to press the button and
activates a 30 second countdown on the
bomb with time running out wang realizes
that he has to make the ultimate
sacrifice so he runs towards the ocean
alone while running wang has a lot of
thoughts in his mind after all the
experiences he has had with the women's
clan he finally understands that their
mission is to protect the balance
between nature and life he also
understands the sacrifice that his
father made back then now he has to make
this same sacrifice to protect the clan
soon the bomb explodes in the sea seeing
this muyon screams in agony while the
others weep over the loss of the man who
has made the ultimate sacrifice then the
screen goes black in the post-credits
scene wang is shown miraculously waking
up as it seems that the magic of the
island has resurrected him for his
selfless sacrifice subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching